well nobody is going straight it's a
view to them when she moves I talked to
her in the evening when I read stories
to my children I do the same for the
baby
focus William it's late February 2019
and Natalia is nine months pregnant with
a baby girl it's not her child she's a
surrogate mother she's carrying the baby
for parents from Germany it won't be
long now it's such a joy to hold your
own child for the first time I'll be
happy for them Natalia zone children are
visiting her today for the final months
of the pregnancy Natalia has to live
close to the clinic in a cave normally
she lives with her children and her
partner Demetriou in a town some fifty
kilometers away this is how Natalia
makes money there's virtually no work to
be had here
dimitru earns the equivalent of about
200 euros of course we aim to give our
own children a good start in life it's
not easy to find work here and to
support a family we made this decision
so our children will be better off the
bubble kitchen with Natalia hopes to pay
for her children's education and to
become self-employed she's not the first
surrogate mother in her town an
acquaintance told her she could make a
living by helping other couples to have
children but many questions remain some
practical but also psychological it's
interesting the baby hears Russian the
whole time inside my belly but then
becomes a German child
Natalia has to say goodbye to her own
family for now say hello to Grandma for
me couples from all over the world come
to this clinic on the outskirts of
Kharkov among them the German couple
whose baby daughter Natalia is carrying
they wouldn't talk on camera fearing
they would be recognized at home another
woman from Germany did talk to us we'll
call her Anna she's in her early forties
and is unsuccessfully trying to get
pregnant through in vitro fertilization
six times she and her husband refused to
consider adopting a surrogate mother for
a donor egg cell was the only option
left in Germany that's illegal Anna sees
this as hypocritical in Germany
surrogacy is prohibited even though many
well known and wealthy people do so and
then the youth welfare office treats you
like the worst criminals ever
these cases are lucrative for the clinic
in Kharkov the doctor in charge explains
that a surrogate pregnancy with a donor
egg brings in at least 30,000 euros
sometimes twice that amount it depends
on the specific needs and wishes of the
parents Ukraine hosts a few hundred
surrogate pregnancies each year he says
with demand growing customers are coming
from as far away as Latin America and
Australia more and more are coming
Ukraine has become a popular destination
for would-be parents for what they'd
have to pay for just one attempt in the
u.s. we guarantee a healthy pregnancy
here Ukrainian law makes it easy for new
parents about a month after we last met
Natalia she's back home with her family
the baby she carried inside her for nine
months is now with her German parents
they picked her up right after she was
born
mostly Rudolph cata a moviegoer to be
honest I did feel pretty confused after
the birth they on the one hand you
understand that it's not your child but
on the other you want to know all about
it you've carried it in you for nine
months but I wouldn't call that the
maternal instinct I felt very clearly
that it wasn't mine no no y-your and how
do you feel about it I miss it somehow
of course it's not our child but I've
gotten used to it during the pregnancy
when the baby was born it was almost the
way it was with our two children I would
like to see it again the German parents
want to stay in touch with the surrogate
mother too at least they promised they
would says Natalia would she do it again
she won't rule it out and the demand
there is growing and growing